welcome welcome to the show fellow
citizens Trump's stay the Union address
was last night I'm I'm not sure if you
heard about it it was sort of a little
minor understated event I think maybe
they aired it on c-span or something and
here's what I'll say about the State of
the Union I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time on it because in fact I assume that
you have heard plenty of coverage about
it but it was as everybody on the right
degrees and even some on the Left seemed
to be saying a wonderful speech
Donald Trump as I've argued from the
beginning Donald Trump is is much better
script in his unscripted campaign speech
ramblings seem to play very well to the
audience that's physically in the room
with him and I think his base still
likes it but I think most people outside
of that are pretty bored with it at this
point but his scripted speeches are
often brilliant and it's true that he
doesn't write his scripted speeches so
this could be seen as another way of
saying Donald Trump is brilliant when
he's not acting like Donald Trump it
seems like a backhanded compliment in
some ways to say oh you know what I love
about him is when he scripted that's the
best part but that wouldn't be the
correct interpretation because even if
he doesn't write the speech these are
still Trump speeches through and through
in that he is willing to say things and
and present things in a certain way that
most other politicians are not
especially Republican politicians which
is why and this is why I wish you to
give more scripted speeches because as
opposed to the unscripted where he's
kind of rambling and going in a million
different directions you don't really
take anything from it there's no message
there's no coherent message in it with
the scripted speeches if he if he stays
on the script and he's willing to let
someone help him formulate it he is he's
willing to say things he can get a
message across and he's willing to put
things in a certain way that they could
be very valuable and that other
politicians other Republicans won't do
so during the State of the Union address
it not just this one but his other State
of the Union addresses we hear things
about abortion protecting life the
family protecting religious liberty
that we wouldn't hear from other
Republic Republicans accepted a very
roundabout way they would allude to it
but Trump just goes right into it and
talks about it in a style we wouldn't
hear from anybody else and but sometimes
though it's kind of subtle which is
surprising because you don't you don't
expect to hear the word subtle and Trump
used in the same sentence but I'll play
a clip for you from last night I'm only
gonna play a couple of clips but this is
him talking about late summer abortion
and there's something subtle in this
maybe you'll pick up on that I thought
was really good listen to this that is
why I'm also calling upon members of
Congress here tonight to pass
legislation finally banning the late
term abortion of baby
whether we're Republican Democrat or
independent surely we must all agree
that every human life is a sacred gift
from God as we support America's moms
and dads I was recently proud to sign
the law providing new parents in the
federal workforce paid family leave
serving as a model for the rest of the
country
okay so he's talking about late term
abortion which is something that no
other Republican would do in a State of
the Union address that's that's not the
subtle part but notice how he throws in
the word the the phrase of babies
he says late term abortion of babies
that's as I said subtle but it's a it's
a very important thing to add because
what are we talking about when we say
abortion because the word abortion
sounds impersonal sounds abstract
detached abortion I just sounds like
this this thing that's hanging out there
that doesn't really affect anybody but
in fact it is it is an act that happens
to someone right and to whom babies so
to say that to make sure you say that
the late term abortion of babies not
late term abortion in general not late
term abortion of fetuses or of
pregnancies but of babies so that was
good and then there was his addressing
of religious liberty and this is is is
not so subtle which is which is which is
good I'm glad it wasn't in fact he's
going right at the issue using phrases
like in America we celebrate faith and
cherish religion and this again is
handled in a way that I think only Trump
would handle it listen to this in
America we don't punish prayer we don't
tear down crosses we don't ban symbols
of faith we don't muzzle preachers and
pastors in America we celebrate faith we
cherish religion we lift our voices in
prayer and we raise our sights to the
glory of God just as we believed in the
First Amendment we also believe in
another constitutional right that is
under siege all across our country so
long as I am president I will always
protect your Second Amendment right to
keep and bear
so for me these are the highlights these
are the take homes right these are the
things that that we should remember
although I think most people of course
will remember as far as what happened in
the speech most people are going to
remember this the most for the past
seven months she has done it all while
her husband sergeant first class
Townsend Williams is in Afghanistan on
his fourth deployment in the Middle East
but ami there is one more thing tonight
we have a very special surprise I am
thrilled to inform you that your husband
is back from deployment he is here with
us tonight and we couldn't keep him
waiting any longer
obviously a beautiful moment there and
this is what's worth talking about now
the routine thing that we do after State
of the Union address is we complain
about the Democrats not applauding this
or that every year we do this the
opposition party doesn't applaud the
president's accomplishments and the
supporters of that president whoever it
is act outraged how could you not
applaud that and that's a topic of
conversation maybe for half a day or so
at most and then everybody forgets about
it and all of that the applauding and
everything and deciding when to applaud
and when not to
it's pageantry doesn't really mean
anything
speaking of which speaking of pageantry
I'm gonna be gonna be very much in the
minority on this I understand so I'm
taking a minority position which is
something you probably not surprised by
I do it somewhat often much to the
chagrin of some people who watch this
show the thing people are really talking
about today of course is this moment
[Applause]
so there's Nancy Pelosi after the speech
on camera tearing up her copy of Trump's
speech now my personal feelings on this
are that I don't really care I I find I
actually find it kind of funny I laughed
when I saw that Pelosi and Trump hate
each other's guts they're constantly
cutting each other down ripping each
other apart taking petty digs at each
other I mean Trump calls her crazy Nancy
that's his name for her that he refers
to her but which I know we take this for
granted but that's that that has not
been normal decorum for presidents in
the past where they have a nickname like
crazy so good so for their political for
the first their political enemies were
the people they're supposed to be
working with calls her crazy Nancy now
okay doesn't really bother me that much
that he says that and I he's not wrong
either so but I see this as as another
volley in that feud and it doesn't
bother me in the the outrage for people
on the right well how dare she do that
how dare she like come on first of all
you don't really care you're not that
offended by it and you can't I mean
considering he's it's it's in line with
the stuff they do and say to each other
all the time it's not that much worse
than anything she's done or said in
regards to her so who cares
um and before that you know she put her
hand out tried to shake his hand he left
her hanging didn't shake her hand you
could make an argument maybe she did he
didn't see that she was trying to do
that I don't know sir I really buy that
I think he I think he did he did leave
her hanging on purpose but but who cares
yet there's been as I said quite a bit
of the sort of performative outrage on
the right about this this moment a lot
of we have to respect the office she has
no respect for the office which for the
record the respect the office stick is
something that people only ever say when
it's their guy in office nobody says
that so the right is now saying respect
the office nobody on the right was
talking about respecting the office when
Obama was in there
that was something the left said respect
the office now they don't respect the
oblem so it's just back and forth and I
just can we just put that aside can we
all admit can we all please admit that
we none of us really respect the office
and in fact none of us even know what
that means exactly what I mean respect
the how do you respect an office it's
it's and if you are going to respect an
office why would you have a blanket
respect for a politician's office this
this is not a monarchy this is not a
king or an emperor that we're talking
about here this is a politician and
they're supposed to work for us they're
our employees that's the way it's
supposed to go doesn't really work that
way but ideally that's how it's supposed
to be and when you say respect the
office you're talking about ideals well
I say the ideal is no they are our
employees they respect us that's a lot
more important than us respecting them I
think with politicians it's the same
with anybody else you respect them if
they earn it and you don't if they don't
that's it whether you're not you think
Trump is earned respect is up to you
it's up each person decides that whether
or not you think Obama earned respect
it's up to you but the idea the fact
that the the notion that they're owed
respect somehow just because they
desperately wanted to run the country
and enough people voted for them I I
don't I don't see it personally so it
didn't bother me that's not my point
though I think and this is the part
where I'm really in the minority I think
this was a rather brilliant political
move by Nancy Pelosi it was a very
trumpian move in a way what she's done
is she's made the whole conversation
after the speech the whole news cycle
about her ripping up the speech the new
cycle is about her ripping the speech
rather than Trump giving the speech
she's got people on the right most most
people most media people on the right
talking about her ripping the speech
rather than amplifying and highlighting
the content of the rather spectacular
speech that Trump gave
so she stole the news cycle this is a
new cycle that rightfully belongs to
Donald Trump and but she took it which
is something Trump does she stole it was
something negative yes but so what her
base will love it she's not at any
political risk because of this the only
people really pissed are Trump fans who
hate Democrats anyway so no loss the
point is just to make the conversation
something else anything else instead of
the positive points of Trump speech so
think about it this is you know I would
go on Twitter this morning the top three
trending topics on Twitter we're about
Nancy Pelosi one of them was hashtag
Nancy the ripper which just makes her
sound like a badass another was Nancy
rocks with leftist defending her then
there was another one Nancy Pelosi
tantrum or something like that and that
was the negative one but who cares after
the speech big speech everyone's in a
lot of a lot of big viral moments in
that speech all the trending topics on
social media about Nancy Pelosi now of
course 10 months from now when it's time
to vote
nobody's gonna care either way about any
of this and the people saying that swing
voters will be swayed against the
Democrats because of this I think are
living in a fantasy land
nobody's gonna ten months from now no
one's going to the polls and voting
based on the fact that Nancy Pelosi
ripped a piece of paper that's that's
not gonna motivate anybody at the post
at ten months from now and that's that's
that's part of the harsh reality of the
world we live in now is that nobody
remembers anything or cares about
anything for more than 48 hours and most
ten months from now you're not gonna be
thinking about any of this you're hardly
gonna remember it okay
now you know Trump is given now three
brilliant State of the Union addresses
can you remember anything about the one
he gave last year and can you remember
any of the outrages afterwards about
what Democrats did can you remember any
of the great lines he hadn't that speed
anything you talk can you remember
anything about it no you can't because
we have very short attention spans and
memories now because there's so much
information coming at us constantly from
all directions and we're absorbing so
much information all the time that we
don't have room it's a it's a logistic
problem we don't have room to store all
of these distant memories by distant I
mean last week so those get discarded
leaving only dim remnants maybe to make
room for the new stuff so which means
that 10 months from now I say this was a
brilliant political move on Pelosi's
part I think it was but ten months from
now I don't think it's gonna hurt her I
don't think it's gonna help her it's
only about winning this particular news
cycle and that's always been Trump
strategies Trump strategy has always
been that you win a new cycle if you
make it about you even if it's bad as
long as it's about you you're sucking up
the oxygen and you win mm-hmm doesn't
matter what it is that's how Trump got
elected in 2016 is that he made almost
every news cycle about him
the for nine months leading up to the
election it was he just took all the
others there's no room for anybody else
now Pelosi too isn't gonna be making
every news cycle about her for the next
ten months but she did win this one I
know we don't yeah look I know four on
the right we don't want to admit it but
I think that's the fact I think that I
think people played right into her hand
and you know if truck if shoes on the
other foot and Trump had done something
like that I know he couldn't have done
that exact thing because Nancy Pelosi
isn't giving the State of the Union
address but if trumpet if chump had done
something like that and stolen the
attention I think everybody on the right
would be hailing his political
brilliance so I would say the same thing
here okay let's move on here's something
that I talked about
don't think I did it's been in a queue
for a while now there is a slate.com has
an advice column where people now how
far do you have to fall in life that you
would be going to slate for advice
that's a different question but they
have an advice column people write in
with questions there was a question
somebody wrote to it to slate a few days
ago that got some attention and I'll
read it to you this is from someone who
signs the letter radical it says I'm a
cyst woman in kind of a classic
millennial sex pickle I'm really
repelled by heterosexuality politically
and personally but I'm also really into
expletive but she means men she's really
into men I've been thinking maybe I
should look for by dudes slash bicurious
gay dudes but I'm not sure how best to
do that rich that's the name of the guy
who gives you advice rich what do you
think of a woman being on grinder or
scruff I do want to be respectful of gay
men's spaces and not horn in where I'm
not welcome but I really would love to
find a vers guy with queer politics
verse out of no idea what that means
a verse go with queer politics who had
put me up for casually dating a woman
what do you think if you were me where
would you look okay now getting the
obvious out of the way millennial sex
pickle would be a great name for a band
maybe just the sex pickles would be a
wonderful name for for some sort of
indie punk band possibly so there's that
now what's the advice that she gets from
rich here on on slate well his advice is
kind of lengthy I won't read the entire
thing but it does boil down to this
he actually recommends that she go to
gay sex parties that's the advice that
she's given that's that's what it's it's
not often this may be the first time in
the history of advice columns that the
advice has been go to a gay sex party
but that's what he that's that's the
advice he gives okay the only thing I
take from
and I know this is obviously an extreme
example that's why it went viral but I
think what you see here is identity
politics as a religion this is someone
for whom identity politics has become a
religion a cult it is taken over her
life to such an extent that she can't
even have normal romantic relationships
and she's going to embrace a weird kind
of abstinence of sexual abstinence at
least abstaining from straight men who
she's attracted to because of her
because of her her political feelings as
she's politically opposed to
heterosexuality what does that even mean
how can you be politically opposed to a
sexual orientation I have no idea and at
any rate whatever it means aren't we not
supposed to be that isn't that been
hasn't it hasn't that been the whole
point of the last 15 20 years you're not
supposed to be opposed to sexual
orientations well yes there's a lot of
contradiction there but the real point I
take from this as I said is this is what
identity politics does to a brain this
is identity politics taken to its it's
logical yet extreme extent and this is
what it does to your brain so stay off
identity politics kids speaking of brain
damage I want to get two emails in a
second but first I wanted to just tell
you maybe as a disclaimer if I've seen
maybe a little bit off these past few
days there's a reason for that I think
it may be because I have suffered brain
damage well additional brain damage on
top of the brain damage I'd already
suffered probably as a baby at least
that's what most people assume when they
hear me share my opinions on things
anyway you see over the weekend I was
downstairs in the living room and I
heard and the twins were upstairs and I
heard from upstairs this this thumping
sound it's like kind of dull thud thump
bang
sort of sound and and then I listen
closer I heard ever every thump it was
followed by cackles of laughter that's
never a good sign okay because that
means my kids are banging something and
finding it funny and that's that's a
combination of noises as a parent of
young children especially that you
sibling never want to hear I as most
parents know the worst noise to hear
when your kids are in the other room is
no noise the absence of noises is the
most terrifying but laughter and banging
this is a pretty bad one so I go
upstairs I find my son
literally banging his head on the ground
on the hardwood floor ground and
laughing hysterically and I come to find
out that they're playing a game that
they've invented and I don't know how
many times they've played it in the past
hopefully not too many but um their play
gave me a medic called hard or soft
that's the name of the game and the way
it works is like this one of them flips
a coin and if it lands on tails then the
other has to bang his head on the soft
carpet if it lands on heads you have to
bang your head on the hard ground that's
harder soft now of course this was a
this the way that this this was being
played is that his twin sister my
daughter she was the one doing all the
coin flipping and he was doing all the
head banging unsurprisingly and so of
course I did play the game with them for
a few rounds I ended up getting hard
like two or three times in a row I think
they were I'm pretty sure they rigged it
so they found a way to trick daddy and
the banging his head on the ground they
did do that and I should stipulate that
my wife did not find this game funny at
all I told them to go downstairs and
show it to my wife and show it to mommy
and she she was not not amused something
about concussions or something or other
I don't know honestly I was impressed by
the ingenuity it was sort of like it's
like a child's version of Russian
Roulette and I and maybe I should be
disturbed that they came up with that
but I was I was somewhat proud
all right let's uh these are the kinds
of games that kids come up with and I
guess you know we have a whole thing
where we don't let them watch a lot of
TV so we're one of those parents
we're very we tend to be strict with the
TV maybe this is the lesson we learned
you don't let them you don't let them
watch TV there and there's literally
beat their heads against the floor maybe
the TV's better let's go to emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Adam says you say
ketchup is for kids but what if ketchup
is put on meatloaf before baking it or
do you prefer ketchup free meatloaf why
in god's name would you put i've heard
of this custom but why would you put
ketchup on meatloaf now you know you're
not putting ketchup on meatloaf because
you're supposed to be topping the
meatloaf with bacon obviously do you
make meatloaf without bacon is that a
thing that people do why would you ever
do that what would be the point of that
so no ketchup does not belong anywhere
near meatloaf or anywhere near any other
kind of food ketchup is a sugary sweet
faux tomato mucus it does not in if it
enhances the food it's only that only
tells you that the food is bad if you're
if you know how to properly make a
hamburger properly seasoned french fries
or anything else in my package alone if
you know how to really make those dishes
it shouldn't need ketchup this is from
Aaron says dear Matt I think you are
completely wrong about the girl who
talked her boyfriend into killing
himself
what she engaged in while morally
atrocious was pure speech she did not
assist him in any way or other than by
encouraging him when it comes to legal
situations we have to put our own
feelings aside and look at the
constitutional issue the First Amendment
says that Congress can make no law
abridging freedom of speech go back and
read it there are no exceptions
whatsoever mentioned the Fourteenth
Amendment says that the rights in the
Constitution apply to the states does
not leave an exception for free speech
so this girl was exercising her First
Amendment rights when she said what she
said I fully acknowledge that you
personally disapprove of the way in
which she exercised them but that's
irrelevant
she was exercising them that's all that
matters as for the slippery slope
because you don't seem to understand
here's what it
is if the government is allowed to
punish people for saying things even
deeply offensive things and things that
result in people doing horrible actions
what's to say that some judge in the
future doesn't come along and decide
that your opinions and your beliefs are
too offensive to be allowed to be said
what if you're the one being carted off
to prison for incitement 20 years from
now or hate speech or harassment or any
other such nonsense I can't wait to hear
the well that's different
everyone is conveniently everyone
completely believes that their own
beliefs and opinions are deserving of
protection if and when they come for you
using the same rationalizations to
destroy your constitutional rights as
they did to her baby then you'll
understand the slippery slope you don't
have to agree with what the girl said I
certainly don't and I agree with you
that she's an atrocious human being but
the issue being explored here is whether
or not she had a constitutional right to
do what she did and in that case she
certainly did the punishment for these
sorts of things should be done at the
social level not at the legal level the
law should stick to punishing
actions not speech that really really
really really hurt our feelings I know
you're going to say that speech is an
action but I'm talking about the
expression of an opinion and a sentence
you should kill yourself is not an
action it's an opinion and even if it
said a thousand times to the same person
it remains just that an opinion Erin
okay Erin so you're presenting a concept
of free speech where in literally
anything that is set out loud
anything is legal is as you say pure
speech as long as it's not accompanied
by physical action and even if it is I
would assume you would say it's the
physical action that's the problem not
the speech I'm not straw Manning you
right that's what you just said that is
what you said okay that's the vision of
free speech that you are presenting here
correct but I noticed you didn't
actually engage with my strongest
argument which which had
be a calculation on your part because
there's no way you missed it which is
that what Michelle Carter did was very
similar almost identical in kind to what
Charles Manson did the death toll for
Manson was was larger but that's
irrelevant for our purposes the fact is
he using words brainwashed a group of
followers of followers of groupies of
his and convinced them to go out and
kill people and they did so you're
saying that Charles Manson never should
have gone to jail you're saying that in
fact a dangerous charismatic psychopath
willing to and capable of and guilty of
already brainwashing others to commit
violent acts should be allowed to remain
on the street free even after he sends
his millions to go to his minions to go
kill people that's what you're saying
you you made no attempt to draw a
distinction between this this version of
free speech you're articulating and
Charles Manson's I can only assume that
you think he's covered he has to be
according to what you said and then what
about calling in a bomb threat if
there's no bomb it's just speech right
what about slander no physical damage is
done if somebody goes out in public and
calls you a child molester for example
well they aren't they aren't physically
doing anything it's all verbal and maybe
it's their opinion that you are now
you're not but it's their opinion that
you are that's their opinion right
say that it's okay to express your
opinions as long as the opinions are
true well that's a slippery slope isn't
it I assume that's not a a stipulation
you would put on this well you didn't
you said pure speech if you're saying it
it's fine that's what you said so if
somebody goes out and accuses you of
child molestation rape any man most
horrible things in the world damages
your reputation because of it you get
fired from your job whatever well they
didn't do that they're not the ones who
fires you they're not that whatever
happening even if even if you know
you're they whip up your neighbors
against you and then one of your
neighbors kills you and on the belief
that you're an abuser of children well
they didn't do it all they did was they
said it they expressed an opinion
according to you perfectly perfectly
legal or at least it should be what
about somebody who shares secrets with a
foreign enemy what about someone in the
government share secrets well as long as
those as long as they are sharing it by
saying it all verbal sure speech lending
no material support to them it's all
verbal just expressing themselves should
that be legal according to you yes I
could go on and on here okay
the point is that obviously you can't
literally say whatever you want in all
situations there are limits and
obviously our founders never intended
free speech to be an absolute unyielding
dictum that legalizes literally anything
and everything that a person might
verbally say or or write okay just like
the right to bear arms it says right to
bear arms yes but I assume like we
talked about a few days ago I assume you
would agree that there are some limits
on that for example I assume you would
agree that your neighbor Jim should not
be allowed to own a nuclear missile i I
would assume that that's a maybe I'm
being wrong maybe you think that right
to bear arms means that you can even
walk around nuclear missiles or maybe
you couldn't really walk around with
them and be a little heavy but you can
have them your garage
but that is not what our founders
intended and you know what even if they
did intend it that way which they didn't
but even if they did that would be crazy
and there's no reason why we should have
to live by their craziness in perpetuity
for all eternity just because it was
their opinion they're not gods I mean
they wrote what they wrote but whatever
their personal opinions were doesn't
doesn't necessarily mean we're beholding
to that forever and it could never be
changed but anyway that's irrelevant I
don't get hung up on that because it's
it's it's clear that that's not what
they intended to do they didn't intend
to legalize slander or death threats or
things of that nature so we have in this
country restricted many kinds of speech
all the kinds I listed and we have to be
able to restrict them otherwise imagine
living in a country where slander is
legal which verbal treason is legal
death threats are legal on and on all
the things I've imagined imagine living
in a country where you can do all of
that without any kind of penalty but
that's not the kind of country we live
in or have ever lived in ever and yet
and and yes I know you I know you might
say well then it's not free speech and
yeah I agree with you this is what maybe
I don't know if you watch the show a few
days ago but we were talking about this
and concepts like equality rights free
speech free you know that we attach the
word free to think these are not these
are these are imprecise words and they
they're not literally true and I think
we need we should probably be using
different words we're we're grasp
a concept we're trying to describe
something but I think we're describing
it in a way that is confusing because
yes I would I would openly say that we
talk about free speech we don't really
mean it literally now there is a truth
there there is a certain kind of speech
that should be free but not all speech
is free and what so what kind of speech
well we happen to live in a country
where you can go out and express pretty
much any point of view you want without
reprisal by the government pretty much
any point of view any sort of idea about
culture or politics critical opinions of
the government so on and so forth we
still live in a country where you can go
and do that now you may be in for it
when it comes to the big tech companies
you may get kicked off a Twitter or
Facebook or whatever and I'm not a fan
of that but that's a different thing so
your slippery slope hasn't really panned
out this thing with Michelle Carter it's
not going to make the slope any slippery
or hers was an extreme case of her not
just saying kill yourself one time but
of a of a prolonged campaign to
manipulate a mentally ill person to kill
themselves this is so obviously illegal
so clearly a crime that the only way to
think otherwise is to have a laughably
simplistic idea free speech and one that
completely ignores how free speech is
actually interpreted legally and has
always been interpreted legally I mean
what if I I mean I could spend all day
talking about the absurd extremes that
you would now justify with your with
your vision of free speech but what if I
were to go up to somebody let's say a
mentally insane meth addict who's
currently high on meth and I were to go
up to him and I would start whispering
in his ears doubt in his ear telling him
that all these bad things that you've
done to him I could say even had that
guy over there you know the guy insulted
your mother yeah
that guy he uh oh yeah he was used over
there he's talking a lot of a lot of
stuff about you hey you should go you
should go over there and tell him and
show that guy yeah you should go over
there teach that guy a lesson
hey he was saying a lot of horrible
stuff you should you should really yeah
you should go and then he goes over and
beats you within an inch of your life
you're saying I have no response
I am totally legally in the clear I have
purposefully incited this mentally
unstable drug addict to come and beat
you half to death and it worked and he
did exactly what I wanted him to do
you're saying I'm good to go I'm clear I
should face no reproach no legal
penalties whatsoever that's that's
that's just crazy I'm sorry that's
absolutely crazy but if that is really
how you feel then I think you know you
could write another email and just it
and acknowledge I was I acknowledge that
you think Charles Manson never shooting
on to jail that the safe scenario I just
described of sending a crack addict or
meth addict to come and beat you up
should be perfectly legal slander and
you should be perfectly legal calling it
a bomb threat to your work perfectly
legal if you're going to say that any of
those things should be illegal then you
are admitting that there are some
restrictions on speech and if you're
admitting that there are some
restrictions on speech now we just have
to talk about whether or not this thing
will Michelle Carter should be one of
those restrictions but you can't take
this absolute principled stance any more
up saying well no there's it's a based
on free speech we can that is that
argument is gone now now you have to
look at the specifics of this case and
think well should that kind of thing
should be legal be legal in this country
the kind of thing of purposefully really
actively trying to encourage someone to
kill themselves should that be a legal
thing to do and I'm saying no why should
it here's the only by the way here's the
only if this
if we're on a slippery slope with this
if this is gonna lead to anything
because I don't think it leads to it
being illegal for someone to just say
kill yourself online there'd be no way
to enforce that anyway and and there's
obviously a clear distinction to be
drawn between what Michele Carter did
and someone just anonymously kind of by
instinct as a reflex reflexively saying
kill yourself like people do online
there's a difference between those two
things but I think any sane person can
recognize but think about the cases and
they're this there have been plenty of
cases of this of a disturbed person
killing themselves and live streaming it
on the internet and in those cases what
you often find is that people are
watching and encouraging the person to
do it saying yeah I do it yeah kill
yourself right and in this case it's it
this is not a reflexive thing saying to
somebody on Twitter because you don't
like their opinion this is someone who's
really wants to kill themselves and you
are really trying to encourage them to
do it maybe we're leading to a place
where the people who do that are
prosecuted and I say fine great I don't
see that as any dystopian nightmare I
don't see that as oppression or
persecution oh my gosh I can't you mean
I I can't actively encourage a mentally
unstable person to kill themselves I'm
I'm oppressed
I'm persecuted come on let's see this is
for
you says dear mr. walsh my name is
matthew i've been a supporter of the
daily wire for some time I love that you
discuss topics outside the mainstream in
political realm I wanted to tell you
that I've been inspired by the new book
you've written about the Church of
Christ and more importantly the body of
Christ and how we can't wash the gospel
for the good of the world
I'll be looking forward to reading it
soon I want to leave you with this
thought of mine about the State of the
Union last night
any thoughts would be greatly
appreciated what's upsetting what's
upsetting is it isn't going to be about
the best speech of president Trump's
term so far but about the nonsense
speaker Pelosi did thanks yeah well I
agree with you your last statement there
I absolutely agree and that's what I was
saying at the beginning of the show and
I appreciate your thoughts about the
book which I will take this opportunity
to remind everyone that my new book
which comes out February 25th went on
presale yesterday it's called Church of
cowards go on Amazon and order it on
presale right now and finally this is
from Austin says hey Matt I saw you
talking about sentencing differences
between men and women and I wanted to
get your opinion on other sentencing
issues on another sentencing issue
I saw the study from the University of
Michigan that you cited and she also had
a paper on sentencing differences
between whites and blacks
it showed that blacks received 10%
longer sentences than whites while
holding all variables like the crime
committed in criminal history constant I
found a similar study from the US
Sentencing Commission that showed blacks
received 19 percent longer sentences
than whites with the same variables held
constant I'm a conservative and don't
believe in the mystical racism hanging
over everything in our lives but I'm
looking at the data from what seem to be
credible sources and it appears there
could be some racial bias and sentencing
I hope conservatives can look at issues
with an objective eye and not be so
loyal to our ideology like the left so
often is what are your thoughts on this
subject well I haven't seen Austin the
studies that you mentioned I'll look at
them but if it holds that black people
when controlling for all variables
received sentences up to 20% longer than
white people for the same crimes then I
think it'd be impossible to deny a
racial bias I did after all just allege
a gender bias based on the same sort of
statistic so if that's the case then I'm
not all the sudden gonna
I hear there'd be no reason to look it's
never been my position that racism
doesn't exist and I don't consider it a
conservative position to deny all cases
of racism at least that better not be a
conservative position so it would be a
very stupid foolhardy position to take
it's certainly not my position I think
racism doesn't exist of course obviously
it does and the whole problem with with
people on the Left who looked for racism
everywhere and in everything and and and
managed to find it everywhere and in
everything and the ones who say things
like all white people are inherently
racist the problem one of the problems
is that buried under this avalanche of
absurd hyperbole and generalization are
actual cases of racism that get lost in
the shuffle and the word racism itself
loses all meaning because of its chronic
overuse if you if you use it if you take
any word and apply it to too many things
and use it way too much and expand it
into oblivion it's it's gonna lose its
meaning and that's what's happened with
racism which is very unfortunate because
racism is a real thing it's an important
thing for us to talk about but now it's
hard for us to talk about it because
when you say the word racism me as the
listener I have no idea if you're
talking about real racism or you know
this this or just a a white person doing
or saying something completely innocuous
which according to the racial theories
of the left literally anything a white
person does is in a sense a racist act
because they are inherently racist as
part of their nature embedded in
everything they do or nearly everything
it's the same it's the same thing with
false rape claims the position has never
been at least I've never heard anyone
express the position that rape never
happens or doesn't exist that would
obviously be insane it does and clearly
when it happens it is a terrible
terrible evil
but when you have a bevy of when you
have a when you have all these false
rape claims and when the word rape is
used to describe things that are not
rape when for example we're calling an
awkward and regrettable yet consensual
sexual encounter rape the problem there
is that once again real cases of rape
are minimized or forgotten and the word
rape begins to lose its meaning and when
someone says rape now without any
context I don't know if you're talking
about someone being forcibly you know
being being violently forced into a
sexual act
which is what most of us would consider
rape to be or are you talking about you
know a guy and a girl getting together
and having sex consensually and but it
was kind of awkward and the girl
regretted it the next day just based on
the word rape I don't know which way
which what you're talking about
and that's a big problem because I
should know and you know up to about
10-15 years ago we knew if you said the
word rape we all immediately knew what
you meant
same for racism so but yeah I'll take a
look at those studies and we will leave
it there thanks for watching everybody
and listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Robin Fenderson the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]